however my mom uh-huh karaman that
smells weird Oh what is going on you two
now you may or may not know this about
me but I have a dog meet Monica oh hello
everybody how are just how are you doing
my name is Nikita does she look like
Azlan from the neverending story yes
people my dog has a Spanish name for
those of you who don't know what that
means it means dull or in this house
paying the [ __ ] ass now for me I love
my dog
but sometimes the [ __ ] is a tendency to
piss me off and if you're out there you
have a dog just tell me right now that
your dog never makes you mad you need to
shut the [ __ ] up you're telling me right
now that the whole time you had a dog
there wasn't a single day you want to
punch the little [ __ ] right in his nose
ok if you lift me in the neck one more
time we gonna get into a fistfight
if you don't hate your dog at least 6
times a day it means you don't love it
everything that you love is supposed to
make you mad ain't no full house it
supposed to be like seventh heaven if
you guys haven't seen that show you
should watch it sometimes my show is so
[ __ ] up I've never seen a white family
with so many problems
apparently the show is about a pastor
that touches babies to sue you guys
realized that dogs would kind of like
your parents how they always managed to
get under your skin just gave you a
shower get up no no mother every morning
I wake up I want to punch her in the
[ __ ] face cuz she's so damn cute and
I know a lot of you crazy dog lovers
nothing to say who are you married or
she's a living creature Dimitri the hell
are you talking about solar people and I
[ __ ] hate their guts like [ __ ] I mean
just to start off here's just a few
reasons why she makes me mad Oh God what
are you doing in my house the same rule
that applied to me have to apply to her
that's all
which means if I can't [ __ ] or piss on
the floor whatever I want you're not
allowed to either so tell me how is it
that I supposedly own her
but I'm over here walking grooming
feeding and cleaning up after her little
[ __ ] she owns Mac I don't like how this
relationship turn around apparently you
forgot
I saved your [ __ ] ass and it wasn't for
me you would still be in that Mexican
tire shop with that do Paco that had
that 40 in his hand he was a little
drunk listening when he gave me to you
let me ask you something right now why
do you always pee everywhere a bunch of
Pat huh I feel like something you just
do it on purpose just to piss me off
is that what you know to lick me no I am
not that type I like a woman and you
know how she does that I'm like this
[ __ ] a loyal what the hell is this dog
you ain't never come to what I call you
every time she sees a random person she
comes up to the fool
she's known that for years the hell the
other day she read out the gate without
me knowing and the next thing you know
she's in the arms of some random
Filipino man saying it but not you're
dumb are you [ __ ] kidding me I just
gave you shelter and food and you leave
like I never existed ego then learn I
ever like you hurt me were right here
and you know what the [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
you don't when your dog runs away and
some random stranger comes and gives you
back to them you expect to see them a
little scared with the tail in the legs
this [ __ ] look like she had the time of
her [ __ ] life
the thing is if you're a dog owner out
there don't you feel sometimes if you
just do [ __ ] to mess with you look what
you want them to pee on their pad but
they always fits right at the edge
because technically you can't get mad at
them why the [ __ ] you just well I guess
I'm you guys can ask y'all something
personal that you don't ever just like
two little dots all over your house no
just mine uh-huh you would think this
dog was trying to recreate the Mona Lisa
with a butthole and [ __ ] got dead tell
you something when yo you cute a [ __ ]
keep it up but you want a [ __ ] soup
I'll button the gas just kidding
I'm not so sure anymore
Oh what's going on you two no no a lot
of you guys out there are dog owners and
you think I hate my dog I don't I
[ __ ] love the [ __ ] it's just she
just gets on my nerves
some times hair kind of like your
girlfriend you love her but sometimes
you just want to just want to just
but yes every video Wednesday and
Sundays and yes I'm bringing funny fat
bit back because a lot of you guys say
you need it so funny fat bit we'll be
back on Wednesday and Sunday there will
be another video so thank you very much
what am I gonna bring yeah that's weird
coochie-coo boo hoo doo doo doo boo boo
boo boo boo boo boo bathing grooming it
and one hanging Internet Oh Shi oh hey
no don't let them you know you know look
at me look at me when I'm talking to you
hmm
you smell like the sunshine